arrivées lolo êtes donc avec jacques
morali votre comparse à l'origine de ce
groupe village people qui est en train
de devenir quelque chose de gigantesque
sur le plan mondial alors dit comment
est né ce groupe est né dans l'esprit de
jacques morali ce poney dans greenwich
village
après la régie camions roulent à voir à
ce contact et il a remarqué indiens cow
boy à façonner des flashs sur le dos et
l'idée de créer un groupe qui
s'appellerait les gens du village en
anglais village people tout simplement
comme ça
et est ce que bon village people à mon
avis est parti je sais pas combien de
temps ça va durer mais parti pour faire
une carrière très très explosive
bon alors comment est ce que les
professionnels du showbiz américain
réagit c'est ce qu'ils sont un peu vexé
de voir que sont des français qui ont
réussi le coup de l'année
ce qu'on a remarqué très spécial ici aux
etats unis c'est que les américains
n'avaient ni préjugés ni attendu comme
eux mêmes sont une génération quand même
c'est une race très noble pas du tout ça
les a amusés au début que ce soit des
français qui ait pensé à ça ils ont
peut-être un peu regretté de thé avoir
passé humaine tout va jacques morali moi
j'aurais aimé savoir si une réussite
pareil on trouve l assumer sans avoir la
tête qui enfle au moment j'ai pas du
tout la tête enflée je crois que vous ne
connaissez un peu
non je suis très réaliste hic je sais
très bien que ça pourrait s'arrêter
demain et il ya qu une seule chose qui
compte pour moi c'est ma musique
vous avez eu des débuts quand même très
difficile
a paris il ya pas tellement de gens qui
ont cru en vous alors maintenant quand
vous y pensez ce que vous avez de la
haine pour ces gens pas du tout pas du
tout réellement parce que je pense qu'à
l'époque les gens qui croyaient par mois
avec des bonnes raisons parce que je
faisais des disques étaient très bidon
et que ma musique n'était pas encore au
point et que je pense que toutes les
tous les gens qui ont fait les grandes
réussites et se sont estimés eux mêmes
en plusieurs années je pense qu'il m'a
fallu un certain nombre d'années pour
maxime et moi même et pour arriver où
j'en suis d'accord que derrière qui est
digne des stars williams et de toutes
les comédies américaines qui ont bercé
notre enfance ce décor va partir en
voyage puisque les village people
partent en tournée
oui c'est exact je lui parle partent en
tournée et ce décor et le tableau final
du show des village people c'est la
dernière chanson est devenue vu les
canons tirent des tonnes de confettis
sur le public ce sera assez
spectaculaire et la capacité des salles
dans chaque pays on joue 52 villes ce
sont des forums entre
dix mille ha à 55 milles 70 mille
personnes puisqu'on finit à madison
square garden le 24 juin ou ainsi pour
nathan douce soirée à 50 mille cent
mille euros pour être les meilleurs
vendeurs au monde de disques ou hst une
chose faire un show disco c'est une
autre chose
c'est jacky est pas un risque n'y a pas
un risque en ce qui concerne les village
people et peut-être un risque en ce qui
concerne d'autres artistes où la musique
est pratiquement uniquement
instrumentale mais les village people
sont d'abord un groupe et un acte visuel
se donne danse chante
ils perdent 2 litres de sueur art show
chacun donc donc je pense que le public
va apprécier les vertus pole parce que
c'est à mon avis l'un des actes dans le
show-business quelques visuels
[Musique]